[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau de
dimanche en politique merci d'être avec
nous pour une nouvelle saison que nous
débutons avec un retour bonjour françois
rebsamen
bonjour monsieur le maire de dijon
président de la métropole
il y a quelques mois vous aviez quitté
la scène politique par un simple
communiqué et avec un mot qui glace il
faut le dire cancer on a donc juste
envie de vous demander d'abord comment
vous allez en tout cas si vous avez
envie de nous le dire à ce moment là je
vais bien je vais bien je suis de retour
j'ai vécu sûrement l'épreuve la plus
difficile de ma vie
et quand je peux dire quand on peut dire
qu'on va bien mais on en sort renforcé
de cette épreuve
quand vous avez pris du recul cette idée
de retour elle était déjà là elle était
importante elle guide et le pouce ou on
n'y pense pas je suis on y pense bien
sûr bien sûr on y pense il faut avoir
des objectifs il faut garder le moral je
m'adresse à tous ceux qui à un moment où
vous demain ou aujourd'hui sont malades
pour leur dire le moral c'est très
important puis avoir un objectif est
vraiment l'objectif c'était de guérir et
donc de me soigner et pour ça de me dire
que je mettais en parenthèse entre
parenthèses pendant un moment
bien sûr j'ai suivi les dossiers mais je
savais que j'allais revenir il fallait
que je fasse je le fasse quoi voilà
alors à l'annonce de votre retour on a
on est allé demander leurs sentiments au
dijonnais dans la rue écoutez les c'est
quand même admirable d'avoir un cancer
de se mettre en retrait et de revenir
après voilà il aurait pu dire lâchez le
c'est fini la politique
au bout d'un moment il va falloir quand
même aussi qu'ils pensent à ça suicide
succession quoi qui passe la main quoi
le temps qu'il était à la mairie de
dijon
il a fait beaucoup de choses pour la
ville de dijon et notamment le tram la
piétonnisation du centre-ville failli
fait bouger les choses à dijon depuis
qu'il y ait et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle de leur tour de monsieur
rebsamen à dijon alors la santé la
succession le bilan il ya pas mal de
choses vont bien entendre ce rapport
avec les habitants on s'en rend compte
encore plus dans ces moments là ces
moments formidables j'ai reçu des
centaines et des centaines de messages
de soutien et on se dit que ont fait
corps avec une
il est avec ses habitants je crois qu'il
y ait le mandat de maire qui représente
cela ce lien avec nos citoyens nos
concitoyens et donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé
et je veux le dire je peux leur dire
merci d'ailleurs beaucoup beaucoup aidé
tous ces messages de soutien et
d'encouragement
voilà alors et vous avez vécu un moment
incognito dans votre ville aussi ce qui
a dû être un drôle de drôle d'expérience
finalement je voulais dit effectivement
j'étais en train de me reconstruire et
donc je me suis promené dans la ville
sans que personne ne me reconnaissent
avec des lunettes noires et chapeau faut
dire qu'il faisait très chaud cet été
et donc voilà ça m'a permis de voir des
choses de la ville d'ailleurs et
d'essayer de corriger encore des choses
alors avant de parler de la ville et des
élections municipales à venir qui se
profile un peu de politique nationale
tout de même parce que c'est aussi comme
ça que vous êtes revenu à l'occasion à
la rochelle d'une réunion de des élus
socialistes alors qu'on était très loin
des grandes universités d'été du ps on
s'en souvient vous avez été numéro 2
d'un parti qui aujourd'hui n'est on va
dire presque plus rien sur l'échiquier
national et qui encore en sursis
localement avant les prochaines
élections municipales
il s'est passé quoi françois rebsamen
est ce que c'est françois hollande qui a
dilapidé l'héritage est ce que c'est un
parti qui n'a rien compris à la marche
du monde
il faudrait beaucoup de temps pour vous
dire cela j'écrirai sûrement un jour
mais disons que le parti socialiste il
faut aujourd'hui assumer avec lucidité
le bilan 2 du quinquennat précédent
assumer avec lucidité c'est reconnaître
des erreurs il y en a eu mais c'est
aussi porter avec fierté les avancées
sociales que nous avons fait et qui ont
été à mon avis assez peu est assez mal
expliqué
les français n'ont pas du tout intégré
parce que ça dépend lesquels ça ne
dépend lesquels ça dépend lesquels
puisque par exemple ceux qui sont partis
à la retraite à 60 ans après une
carrière l'ont dit savent très bien
qu'ils le doivent
je pourrais parler de du baisse de la
pauvreté dans notre pays et c'est un
certain nombre de choses qu'il faut
qu'il faut porter fièrement et non pas
se cacher et c'est justement le problème
crise des partis sociaux démocrates dans
le monde et en europe de cette idée
politique de ce concept où c'est
spécifiquement aussi français un
quinquennat raté
non non c'est c'est beaucoup plus
profond c'est beaucoup plus profond
quand françois hollande est arrivé en
2012 au pouvoir présidentiel il avait en
réalité il arrivait à contre courant au
moment où on avait subi une défaite
idéologique profonde le libéralisme
avaient envahi les esprits y compris
l'esprit des socialistes et des sociaux
démocrates et donc les touches
social-démocrate tout ce qui a été fait
dans le domaine social ou sociétal par
françois hollande a été balayé par une
j'allais dire une politique de l'offre
nécessaire pour ramener notre pays dans
le haut niveau international et donc ça
n'a pas été compris ça n'a pas été
expliquée ça n'avait pas été réfléchie
et par le ps parle ps et pallois pas
parler par les sociaux démocrates dans
le monde entier et donc il faut
aujourd'hui repenser ce néolibéralisme
qui a que porte
emmanuel macron qu'une porte très bien
d'ailleurs et qui a envahi nos vies qui
a poussé l'individualisme qui parce que
le socialisme
au départ c'est s'occuper de l'individu
et donc il faut remettre l'individu au
centre de notre réflexion
vous venez de voir la photo de françois
hollande juste avant françois hollande
et ce qui est ce qu'il n'est pas un
obstacle à cette réflexion et et à cette
rénovation
on le voit qui courent les librairies
qui laisse entendre que peut-être il
pourrait revenir il pose en photo dans
des magazines après tout ce que vous
venez de dire est ce que c'est pas
est-ce que c'est pas un vrai problème
ah non cadrée moi je pense que sa parole
est utile elle est même très utile parce
que il peut expliquer aujourd'hui il l'a
fait à travers un livre d'ailleurs je
conseille de lire qui a très bon livre
les leçons du pouvoir et donc il
comprend il essaie d'expliquer ses
échecs et mais aussi dit toute sa part
de réussite je je je dis que cela
aujourd'hui si l'année 2017 a été aussi
excellentes qu'elle a été bien sûr
l'élection de d'emmanuel macron apporter
un élan mais les fondamentaux
économiques avait été rétablie sous
françois hollande je pense que les gens
vont voir la différence est plus le
bilan des manuels macro va apparaître
dans l'année qui vient est plus ce qu
elle laisse l'héritage de françois
hollande
enfin de notre héritage celui du
gouvernement mais avec un paradis
quand même françois rebsamen le patronat
le monde économique avait pas de mots
assez durs contre votre gouvernement à
l'époque ils attendaient beaucoup et il
trouve qu emmanuel macron va pas assez
loin
donc en disant que cet héritage
fonctionne aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu en train de refaire
l'histoire et de la verser quand on
n'est pas du tout pas du tout voyez le
comme nous sommes arrivés le taux de
marge des entreprises on apprendre des
choses simples le taux de marge des
entreprise était le plus bas de tous les
pays industrialisés de l'europe et donc
il était à 27 ou 28 % par la politique
de l'offre qu'on a mise en place par le
cic eux
eh bien on a remonté le taux de marge
des entreprise à 33% et les chefs
d'entreprise qui ce qui vraiment j'avais
dire le fond de manière la plus
objective possible reconnaissent par
contre aujourd'hui ils en train à
nouveau diminué et j'en profite pour les
mettre en garde
le cic eux devaient être de 7% cette
année il n'a été en réalité il été
rabotée par emmanuel macron pour être
amené à 6%
attention attention à ne pas à nouveau
faire baisser le taux de marge entre
plaidoyers connaît on veut que
l'économie fonctionne
moi je souhaite d'ailleurs que
l'économie française marche comme elle a
marché en 2010 est parce que c'est mieux
pour nos collectivités mais c'est
surtout mieux pour nos concitoyens
si on comprend bien le parti social tout
cas françois hollande et son
gouvernement ont dû faire on va dire une
politique plus libérale qu'il ne le
pensait pendant leur quinquennat ce qui
est en ce moment ce que certains au ps
reproche à emmanuel macron il est quoi
il est en réalité dans la ligne de ce
qu'avait fait françois hollande où il va
beaucoup plus loin
on se souvient qu'au soir de la
présidentielle vous étiez pas du tout
hostile à emmanuel macron à ce moment là
on vous sent beaucoup plus dur
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus agressif
c'est lui qui a changé c'est vous qui
n'aviez pas compris ce qu'il allait
faire
je pense que il n'est en oeuvre
aujourd'hui une politique qui n'est pas
du tout celle qu'il avait annoncé pour
dire la vérité au niveau économique il y
mène la politique qu'il a choisie mais
le fait de vouloir tout de suite
privilégiez les plus aisés les plus
riches les très riches de ce pays avec
des cadeaux fiscaux incroyable
incroyable que notre pays va payer cher
et notamment la population aujourd'hui
c'est les retraités mais demain c'est
l'ensemble 25 milliards de cadeaux
fiscaux aux plus aisés
vous savez ça ça
creuse sa grève les finances de notre
pays au nord on en aurait besoin
aujourd'hui quand on voit qu'il ya un
plan pauvreté où il ya huit milliards
d'euros pour les quatre prochaines
années alors même qu' on a donné 25
milliards aux plus aisés ce qui ne m'a
pas fait plan pour fraude ce qui ne va
pas mais si bien sûr ce que ce que fait
aujourd'hui macron sais c'est comment
dire c'est un succédané ces implants
pauvreté light par rapport à ce qu'on a
fait d'ailleurs il veut multiplier ce
que j'avais mis en place la garantie
jeunes etc pour voilà donc c'est très
très peu c'est un plan de pauvreté si
j'étais méchant mais je ne le suis plus
si j'étais méchant je dresse un plan de
pauvreté financé par les pauvres vous
n'êtes plus sniper du parti socialiste
non ça fait longtemps que je ne me suis
plus mais en même temps on vous sent
très actif encore sur ce sujet vous êtes
président de la fédération des élus
socialistes
est ce que parler françois hollande mais
ce que vous comptez jouer un rôle
national dans ce qui va se passer au ps
si je peux si je peut apparaître comme
la sagesse un petit peu amener des idées
de la réflexion je le ferai mais mon
rôle dans le parti socialiste limitera à
ça à dire à mes amis
voilà ce que je crois et maintenant à
vous d'agir aussi un on parlera de ce
contexte national tout à l'heure en
abordant les municipales parce que
forcément ça jouera on va d'abord parlé
de dijon et de la métropole
vous dirigez la ville depuis 2001
bonheur on va y consacrer une large
place je sais bien vous aviez en 2001
toute une liste de projets françois
rebsamen
est-ce que dijon en 2018 c'est la ville
dont vous rêviez quand vous vous êtes
installé dans le fauteuil de maire en
2001 j'imaginais même pas je vais vous
dire la vérité que en 2018
on serait arrivé à faire tout ce qu'on a
fait je jeûne jeune j'avais envie de le
faire on avait envie de le faire mais je
ne l'imaginais pas ce poids là et
d'autres défis sont apparus c'est ça la
vie il ya une évolution permanente est
aujourd'hui le grand défi c'est de faire
de dijon la grande ville écologique
française
donc c'est de porter les l'écologie
urbaine ce serait un clin d'oeil à
robert poujade premier ministre de
l'environnement français mais peut-être
date mais je voudrais dire ici que j'ai
toujours dit robert poujade qu'il ne
fallait pas faire un livre sur le
ministère de l'impossible sofame est
sorti au moment de la démission de
nicolas hulot à la la grande mode c'est
les classements de ville françois
rebsamen me paraît que vous adorez ça
puisqu'on est bien classé dijon septième
dans les 50 villes les plus attractives
d'après l'express première du grand est
est ce que ça veut vraiment dire quelque
chose ces classements ne va pas les
prendre à la lettre mais j'allais dire
que toute une accumulation de classement
la ville qui accueille le mieux les
étudiants la ville où il fait bon vivre
la ville où c'est plus facile de se
loger tous savent la vie sportive la vie
culturelle la ville écologique tout
sacré j'allais dire un environnement
favorable pour que la métropole continue
d'avancer un des dossiers en cours
à dijon des gros dossiers c'est la cité
de la gastronomie on en a beaucoup parlé
mais en étant un peu dur pour l'instant
c'est un terrain vague
et pendant ce temps là à lyon les gens
ils vont à la cité de la gastronomie
elle est ouverte
qu'est-ce qui sait qu est ce qui a
cloché à dijon rien rien simplement
c'est un grand projet a lyon c'est un
petit projet est donc à lyon c'était la
réhabilitation du bâti belle
réhabilitation d'ailleurs qui était
faite avec un petit le projet de
gastronomie nous c'est une réalité
d'ailleurs n'est pas ouvert à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
absolument pour être honnête c'est donc
moi je je je vois ce qui est en train de
se lancer ça y est ça commence mais on a
été retardée il faut pas faut pas le
nier par un opposant à la ville de dijon
conseil municipal qui devrait aider le
monde économique qui devrait nous
encourager
café des recours et des recours et des
recours c'est c'est sa manie de travail
aient cessé il est comme ça bon voilà
donc mais c'est c'est très pénalisant
l'aï encore un recours que nous
attendrions il a perdu cinq recours sur
six donc on attend qu'ils perdent le
sixième mais vous savez par exemple
l'école ferrandi c'est une grande
avancée pour notre ville qu'elles
viennent s'installer ici elle n'est pas
à lyon elle va venir à dijon
toutes ces choses là j'en ai vraiment
besoin de ça dijon est déjà au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco il ya
énormément de
risque qu'est ce que ça va apporter de
plus encore encore du rayonnement encore
de l'attractivité encore de l'activité
économique est encore en moins de
chômage c'est eiffage qui est un grand
groupe privé qui construit même qui va
gérer aussi est ce que c'est une bonne
idée
pourquoi c'est pas la ville qui gérerait
un outil aussi important que ça c'est
pas eiffage qui va gérer
eiffage va déléguer et donc c'est par
exemple
fimalac qui va gérer le projet culturel
c'est donc ce sont des spécialistes des
projets culturels qui font des
spécialistes pour un outil comme celui
là aujourd'hui
oui eiffage va pas gérer l'hôtel cinq
étoiles qui va s'installer c'est hilton
dans le même temps vous entendez les
critiques de ceux qui disent c'est eux
qui ont construit ils vont déléguer à
d'autres sociétés ils vont garder la
main là dessus la ville perd lui est lié
mais c'est eux qui mettent l'argent je
m'excuse de dire ça la ville met à tout
petit peu pour la voirie et le parking
mais pour le reste c'est eiffage qui
paye et donc ça ne coûte rien aux
dijonnais donc à partir du moment où ça
ne coûte rien aux dijonnais que ça va
être un grand projet ça va j'allais dire
élargir le centre ville
ça va permettre encore à la ville de
s'étendre un peu dans son dans son
périmètre un parce que je suis contre
l'extension urbaine donc c'est une très
bonne nouvelle
alors c'est long c'est long ça en jambes
leur a peut-être même l'élection
municipale mais j'aime ça ne me dérange
pas autre sujet alors qui est agité par
l'opposition mais qui est présent dans
les conversations aussi la sécurité les
incivilités qui serait en augmentation à
dijon est ce que c'est la conséquence
d'une ville dont on sait qu'elle est
plus ouverte plus piétonne plus
étudiante qu'elle n'était est ce que
c'est une conséquence est ce que c'est
la conséquence du fait que la police a
moins de moyens vous le vous l'envisagez
comment est ce que vous entendez ces
critiques là c'est tout ça c'est tout ça
à dijon est une ville attractive pour
tout le monde c'est une ville attractive
pour tout le monde donc il y a trente
cinq mille étudiants qu'ils font du
bruit ils sortent ils boivent je dis les
choses clairement
je lutte contre ça pour le pour leur
apprendre pour leur dire d'ailleurs
qu'il faut qu'il fasse attention ils
peuvent être agressés quand il
ils sont ivres donc voila mais en même
temps c'est une ville à vivre et toutes
les grandes villes françaises sont
confrontées à ce problème là plus une
baisse des effectifs
de la police nationale la nuit très peu
très peu très peu très peu
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait travailler on
fait travailler la police municipale
jusqu'à une heure du matin maintenant
c'est madame koenders que je veux
féliciter pour leur emplacement qu'elle
a fait pendant que j'ai devancé oui mais
celle là il fallait que je le dise parce
que c'est elle qui s'occupe de ses
problèmes là maintenant je lui ai
délégué ce sujet elle le fait très bien
elle a fait des réunions publiques là
dessus le procureur de la république la
justice est avec nous le préfet est très
mobilisé donc on va y arriver mais c'est
pas facile et par tous et par tous et on
a vu commander une vidéo sur des
incivilités sur un restaurant a été
partagé un nombre de fois c'est
incroyable donc on sent qu'il ya une
sensibilité là dessus ali alors dijon
s'est pas chicago je vais quand même le
dire aujourd'hui
dijon s'est pas non plus des grandes
villes françaises avec c'est pas
marseille 1 on va dire des choses comme
ça aussi
donc disons c'est une ville qui est
relativement calme relativement calme
mais relativement calmes ça veut pas
dire très calme et ceux qui poussent à
cela ce qui exacerbe les tensions ferait
bien d'aller voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs un peu alors voilà vous parler
d'écologie tout à l'heure un mot en lien
avec la piétonnisation qui est en train
d'être terminé la dernière tranche à
dijon il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui s'étonnent de choix qui sont
extrêmement minéraux sans arbres parce
que vous parlez de villes écologiques et
et face à la canicule on parle beaucoup
de végétalisation des centres villes il
ya même une pétition qui vient d'être
lancée à dijon pour qu'ils aient plus
d'arbres dans ces espaces là vous
l'entendez vous vous dis c'est un
deuxième temps après l'écologisation de
la ville où où ça va rester comme ça ça
doit pas être neutre quand même ce genre
de démarche parce que on a planté avec
le tram près de 5000 arbres avant là où
il ya aujourd'hui un espace piéton il y
avait une rue mais il n'y avait pas des
arbres n'ont plus le coeur de ville est
et restera minérale on a mis les
fontaines quand on pouvait mettre des
fontaines c'est le cas place de la
libération
mais je vais pas mettre des bacs à sable
place de la libération
par contre vous verrez nous envisageons
dans les aménagements du musée des
beaux-arts de m quelques arbres lien il
ya sur le petit square des ducs
magnifique square des ducs à des arbres
centenaires plusieurs fois centenaires
un qui est tombé d'ailleurs deux ans et
donc il ya des espaces comme ça où il
faut en avoir il ya beaucoup d' espaces
verts dans dijon beaucoup d'espacés
verts il y a des squares etc
mais c'est un sujet recchi qui prend
effectivement parce que avec encore plus
de prégnance après une année de canicule
vient cela bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
et alors qu'on vienne pas me dire qu'il
ya des feuilles par terre dans un mois
et demi ça va venir bien sûr c'est vrai
que les arrières le maire de leurs
feuilles
il reçoit beaucoup de lettres le maire
là dessus oui sur les rues la propreté
oui disons une vingtaine par jour quand
même on parle et on évoqua la métropole
tout à l'heure et en même temps n'étant
brutale en fête à dijon le dijonnais
savent vraiment pas à quoi ça sert la
métropole en fait ça sert à quoi
bah il va falloir qu'on leur explique
encore j'essaie de faire ce travail de
pédagogie mais ils le savent ils savent
que c'est la métropole qui a fait le
zénith ils savent que c'est la métropole
qui a financé la piscine olympique
ils savent que les grands projets
aujourd'hui sont financés par la
métropole parce qu'il profite pas qu'à
dijon mais profite aux deux cent
soixante mille habitants de la métropole
puisqu'on parle de métropole juste un
dernier mot en souriant un petit peu par
rapport à nos voisins de besançon on
sait que il ya souvent quelque chose
d'assez tendue a besoin de beaucoup
moins à dijon dans la rivalité entre les
deux villes vous vous en tenez compte au
delà des formules à l'emporte-pièce ou
des polémiques a pu avoir mais est ce
que dans l'aménagement on va dire du
territoire un terreau d'une grande
région vous en tenez compte et que le
lien existe en réalité alors qu'on est
con n'est pas en réalité dans la
rivalité mais dans une complémentarité
ne se reprenait dans la complémentarité
moi je je me moque un peu de ce qu'ils
veulent absolument exacerbé ces tensions
bon chacun est à sa place besançon un
rôle à jouer dans l'aménagement du
territoire bourgogne franche comté bien
évidemment et donc moi je dis aux
bisontins
je trouve que jenson est une belle ville
donc il faut qu'elle développe que les
les élus développe cette ville
voilà mr e en creux ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas fait assez
voilà c'est pas ça qu'on doit comprendre
que vous avez bien fait de me il y avait
aucune aucun propos de malfaisants
d'enfin
les intentions malfaisantes dans ce que
je disais c'est aux élus bisontins et
aux bisontins jeunes de développer leur
ville bon voilà il faut il faut des
hôtels dans une ville si on veut attirer
il faut avoir cette volonté chevillée au
corps
moi je ne doute pas que certains l'ont
là bas puisque vous parlez de propos
mais faisant on va parler des prochaines
élections municipales
avec un peu d'humour en disant qu'il y
en aura sûrement 2020 en 2001 vous aviez
parlé de trois mandats maximum en disant
trois mandats c'est bien lors des
dernières élections municipales sur
notre plateau d'ailleurs vous aviez
évoqué que ça pouvait être votre dernier
mandat de maire de dijon
c'est le cas j'ai évoqué l'idée ça
pouvait être mon dernier mandat de maire
de tuchan si vous n'êtes plus maire de
dijon est ce que vous seriez autre chose
par exemple président de la métropole
que vous souhaiteriez le garder oui
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse ont
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse c'est à voir j'ai pas vous
voyez à la jupe et qui veut faire un
quatrième mandat
martine aubry qui veut faire un
quatrième mandat donc à beaucoup de
mères qui se disent voilà j'attends
encore un peu je vois mes opposants
locaux bien sûr sont dans les élections
moi je suis dans l'action donc c'est la
différence moi je suis je travaille
eux ils voient comment ils peuvent se
positionner donc on n'est pas du tout
sur le même terrain on a le temps ce
sera une façon ce serait une façon de
garder le pouvoir
est ce qu'il ya une forme d'hypocrisie
en disant je me retire de la mairie mais
je garde la métropole parce qu'on sait
maintenant que le pouvoir est à la
métropole
non le pouvoir la proximité là le lien
avec les habitants d'une ville ça reste
le maire ça reste le maire les grands
projets c'est la métropole mais c'est la
métropole avec la ville ou avec les
villes que ce soit avec le nouvel ami
etc
par contre le lien j'allais dire le lien
de proximité c'est vraiment le maire qui
l'a et j'ai remarqué que nathalie
koenders et est arrivé à avoir ce lien
avec les habitants de notre ville elle
m'a elle m'a remplacé elle a montré
qu'il avait les qualités pour être mère
quoi pour voilà jenson a compris parce
que vous avez compris doit comprendre on
doit comprendre ça pour vous celle qui
doit mener la liste
chacun doit vous succédez chacun
comprend ce qu'il veut pour le moment
rien ne prépare à cela
nous travaillons nous travaillons
ensemble la main dans la main et qui
ensemble des élus je voudrais remercier
pierre pribetich
métropole ils ont fait un travail
formidable pendant que j'étais pas là
j'ai suivi j'avais les dossiers quand
même il m'arriva les dossiers j'ai vu ce
qu'ils avaient fait c'était très bien et
c'est une belle image de la vie quelques
jours avant votre retrait on avait
appris le résultat d'un sondage qu'un
sondage annuel commandée par la mairie
68% d'opinions favorables pour vous 91%
satisfaits de vivre à dijon 75 %
d'approbation de l'action l'équipe
municipale
es que c'est un énorme avantage pour
envisager de conserver la majorité ou sk
contexte national peut tout à fait
balayer tout ça le contexte national
pèse il a pesé en 2014
il ya une triangulaire majorité vous
étiez au pouvoir et en été on se
rappelle que c'était un vote sanction le
parti socialiste a été malheureusement
les municipales c'est souvent l'occasion
d'un vote sanction pour ceux qui sont au
pouvoir
je vais pas dire heureusement nous ne
sommes plus au pouvoir mais c'est vrai
que ça pète
mais le poids des merles la qualité du
travail fourni
le lien avec les habitants permettent de
surmonter ces moments difficiles et donc
on voit quelle que soit qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche
dd mère qui résistent assez vague c'est
ce que nous avons fait à dijon on sait
que le groupe d'élus passé chez en
marche a quitté votre majorité emmenée
par le député didier martin dommage qui
a été précédemment votre adjoint est ce
que vous vous préparez à on va dire que
la république en marche décide
d'attaquer la ville basse ils veulent
attaquer la ville attaqueront la ville
un mois je vois là je lui dis c'est
dommage parce que je vois j'ai du
respect pour le président de la
république je l'appelle pas manu j'ai du
respect pour la fonction mais je
critique sa politique
je critique la politique qu'il a à
l'égard des collectivités veulent
critiquer trop s qui n'a pas le risque
que symboliquement le emmanuel macron
disent il faut aller prendre dijon et
sanctionner quand il le dira puis on
verra ce qui se passera mais moi je vais
pas faire ce que je pense je suis un
homme libre très libre non encore plus
libre depuis que j'ai vaincu la maladie
donc je dis ce que je pense
ou alors c'est assez simple je pense que
la politique qui mène est une politique
d'injustice sociale d'injustice fiscale
et rien ne m'empêchera de le dire je
pense que cette politique est pas bonne
pour notre pays
voilà si humaine une il ya des mesures
qui sont bonnes j'ai soutenu par exemple
la div
lyon des classes par deux dans l'est
dans l'est dans les zones prioritaires
de l'éducation donc qui est 12 élèves en
en rép
enfin au cp une bonne nouvelle bonne
mesure les bonnes mesures je les
soutiens mais ce qui fait aux
collectivités locales c'est pas bien
demander des efforts aux collectivités
locales et ne pas les faire lui même sur
la politique de l'état un exemple pas
beaucoup de chiffres 13 milliards
demander d'efforts aux collectivités
locales
le budget de l'état augmente le déficit
cette année 17 milliard voilà donc 17
milliard de dépenses supplémentaires
pour l'état et 13 milliards d'économies
vous avez oublié que vous avez le
gouvernement françois hollande à baisser
les dotations général le collectivisme
de diyala aussi le 10 mai à laon 90 13
milliards alors que la situation n'est
plus la même
10 milliards quand il ya zéro de
croissance eh bien les collectivités ont
fait l'effort il l'avait déjà fait sous
sarkozy
moi je me suis pas gêné un g10 c'était
le gel sous sarkozy ça a été le surge
elles soient lents ne va pas faire mieux
mais là là c'est injuste et c'est ça qui
me révolte un peu pour terminer nous
reste minutes nîmes 32 minutes après
trois mois oui après trois mandats de
maire françois rebsamen
après cette épreuve ces cinq mois qu'est
ce qui donne encore envie de se lever le
matin
dijon la ville les habitants
j'aime cette ville j'aime ses habitants
et c'est ce qui me c'est ce qui me fait
c'est ce qui me fait bouger c'est ce qui
me fait encore avoir envie d'être avec
eux et de porter des projets et un grand
alors un grand projet des grands projets
encore cia
j'en ai j'en ai par exemple aller bien
sûr j'en ai je vous révèle quelque chose
je dis oui je voudrais un grand musée
d'art contemporain après un grand musée
des beaux-arts
on aura un grand musée d'art
contemporain ça se serait porté par la
métropole si vous présidez la métropole
ou porté par la ville les deux mais de
2,2 merci beaucoup françois rebsamen
d'être venu d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour revenir mais il faudra
me réinviter parce que ses courses et
c'est long et c'est court en même temps
ici et les élections municipales vont se
profiler probablement on va dire que la
bataille va commencer en début d'année
sûrement d'accord moi j'ai encore un an
de travail en 2019 et on verra en 2020
je pense que les gens ne soient pas du
tout dans les élections municipales à
en janvier 2000 20 février de ville
merci beaucoup encore une fois c'est la
fin de cette émission rester avec nous
pour la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique l'invité de francis letellier
ce sera valérie rabault la présidente du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée qui
s'appelle à nouveau socialiste je sais
que ça vous fait plaisir on reste dans
le thème de la journée en développement
de et dimanche prochain des missions
sortira du studio pour un débat sur la
chasse et la protection animale
bon dimanche au revoir et à bientôt
[Musique]
là